you know sometimes I'm listening to a
Disney song and I just can't shake the
similarities that it has to something
else now I can't play the samples for it
here because you know copyrights but you
can look both songs up and hear it for
yourself or heck I'll put some of my
favorite examples up on Twitter if
you're interested at matpat GT because
Twitter is the Wild West and anything
goes there for instance I am constantly
confusing the opening of tangles when
will my life begin with the who's
pinball wizard those guitar chords and
rhythms are undeniably similar then
there's the lion sleeps tonight which
really sounds a lot like the Zulu chant
song Jubei oh wait that's a real story
with the tragic outcome
check out the Netflix documentary the
lion's share if you're interested on
that little dark secret but probably the
strangest comes from our subject for
today frozen - you know that haunting
call that Elsa hears in the song into
the unknown that makes her go exploring
north well it was derived by composers
Robert Lopez and Kristen anderson-lopez
from the D s ear a part of the
traditional Catholic Requiem Mass and
you know what other frozen movie
prominently features the DC Ray The
Shining seriously right at the beginning
of the movie does this mean that the two
potentially share a universe no no it
doesn't but does it mean that I've now
spent an enormity of this movie where
Elsa discovers a haunted Ice Hotel and
then gets chased by Olaf while he hacks
at her with an axe yeah yeah it does
count Elsa years Olaf
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that ventures into the unknown
every week to lift the fog of
uncertainty that separates us from the
outside world so that extended metaphor
probably didn't make sense if you
haven't seen frozen - but no worries it
barely makes sense if you have seen
frozen - so nothing lost nothing gained
anyway speaking of frozen - seamless
segue alert it's no secret that I've
thought about this movie a lot wondering
everything from how cold it needs to be
to freeze Elsa tip who taught Kristoff's
reindeer to sing must have been
Christoph and where are all those sick
electric guitar riffs coming from when
he's in the middle of the forest
is it the sixth elemental creature the
elemental spirit of ATS radness but one
thing that stands out the most in this
movie is Olaf who diz evolves from being
a naive magical snowman and frozen one
to the version that we see in this movie
where he's the equivalent of a toddler
that's chugged about twenty Pixy sticks
and insists on telling you every thought
that enters his head and well that might
come across as annoying well it kinda is
but still it actually gives us one of
frozen twos most memorable scenes and
best running gags where Olaf spouts some
of his favorite science facts it's as
random as it sounds and I can only
assume was included because the writers
had watched some wacky WatchMojo
listicle and really wanted to show that
they'd done their research for this
movie no I'm used to watching Disney
movies and really having to think about
what is theory worthy in that movie so
didn't really hand it to Disney on this
one thanks for the assist there guys why
dig for a theory when the movie hands
one right to you on an icy silver
platter so on today's episode of film
theory we're looking at Olaf's
scientific facts from frozen - and
determining how well Disney is teaching
our children is all off the 2020s
equivalent of Bill Nye the Science Guy
or is he peddling a bunch of onion level
Snapple facts the answer is actually
more nuanced than you would expect
number one right side turtles can
breathe through their bodies frozen to
ends its little fact list with a butt
joke but I'm starting it off with one
because we're classy AF here on film
theory and surprisingly but respiration
is indeed a science fact when turtles
hibernate in the winter they need very
little oxygen to sustain themselves
so rather than breathing in and out with
their lungs the oxygen from the water
that passes over their little turtle
Toshi's is able to permeate into their
bodies for respiration it's a process
known as Chloe coal respiration it's not
just Turtles who do it frogs salamanders
even some snakes can do it don't know
how you learn about that one in the days
before the internet snowman that little
fire lizard you just met might not want
to go to sleep with you around probably
be creeping up on him for science
number two no wombats proof squares see
what I did there made the poop one
number two it's another one of those
highbrow little details you can expect
unlike Disney content now first small
nitpick a square is a two-dimensional
shape with zero thickness so no nothing
poops and squares
however if by squares all off meant
cubes then yes
this is indeed another science fact we
know for sure that wombat Duty is in
little blocks that look like this even
weirder scientists aren't a hundred
percent sure how wombats do it I mean
we're wasting all this money trying to
get ourselves up into space and yet we
can't dedicate any money into
researching the really important
questions how wombats are able to Cuba
fie their turds
come on science anyway most think that
wombats use the cubes to identify
territory and that the little blocks are
less likely to roll away this is gross
but mildly interesting which fun fact
was the working title for the show when
we were starting at number three you
know we think four million times a day
get back on track Olof that's big ol
science fiction in fact it's not even
close to being right humans blink a
bunch usually about 15 to 20 times per
minute and considering that we're
supposed to be asleep for a solid seven
hours per day it means that we're
blinking about 20,000 times per day on
average orders of magnitude away from
Olaf's number to get to Olaf's four
million even if you never slept you'd
still have to blink more than forty six
times per second so unless you're an
insomniac whose eyes like to mimic
strobe lights you're not blinking four
million times per day I literally have
no idea how they could have gotten to a
number that is that wrong anyway number
four is you know men are six times more
likely to be struck by lightning I can't
say those numbers are necessarily
perfect but we'll call this one a
science fact according to popular
science between 1995 and 2008 men
accounted for 82% of all the deaths by
lightning strikes in the US is it chance
does it have something to do with men's
body chemistry is Zeus just trying to
reduce the male population so he can
seduce more earth ladies vilnius
actually a much more simpler explanation
into immortal words of sailor jay
because men are stupid men have been
found to be far less likely to abandon
outdoor activities like fishing golfing
and camping when there's a thunderstorm
and wouldn't you know it that's when
they're getting zapped so if you're
outside in the thunderstorm chances
significantly increase that you're gonna
be the one who gets hit by lightning
when it does strike someone truly a
shocking thing i know and finally number
five did you know that water has a
memory true fact it's disputed by many
but it's true I saved this one for last
because well this isn't just an Olaf
science fact it's pretty much the whole
movies thesis that there are these
elemental
energies that connect us to the past and
to other people and that water has it
water has memory water has frozen really
wants us to believe that this is true
water has memory what is it is it fair
to say that water has anything that can
be even remotely classified as memory
well that's a more complicated question
and the main topic for today's theory
does water have memory and what would
that mean if it did the answer to that
question like the answer to most weird
questions starts off in the 1980s cue
that 80's elemental guitar riff in 1988
french researchers Jacques benveniste
results of a study in the scientific
periodical Nature which showed water's
surprising ability to remember
substances which had been in it
previously the study was named human
basophils degranulation triggered by
very dilute antiserum against IgE hoo
boy doesn't that one get you psyched to
read it real page-turner that one anyway
the study basically worked like this
benveniste news team started by
isolating some very small amounts of
human antibodies which attack bacteria
and viruses in the body they then
diluted those antibodies in water to the
point where the concentration of the
antibodies was effectively zero they
were obviously still in there but they
were surrounded by so much water in the
sample that the solution shouldn't have
been any more reactive than just plain
water
he then agitated the water which is
fancy science talk for they shook it
really hard before taking samples and
testing them by introducing what are
known as basophils a type of white blood
cell that reacts to the presence of
antibodies and the basophils reacted if
that was to science eforea it basically
amounts this I'm allergic to dogs right
so I walk into an absolutely massive
room massive room think like a room the
size of an airport hangar all your
normal stuff is in there but like it is
huge huge and in there somewhere is a
single small Chihuahua I walk in and
boom I sneeze even though it's one small
dog in an otherwise massive room that
wouldn't make me sneeze that is what
happened in this test the basophils
sneezed in a giant room where there was
only one dog in essence benveniste part
its findings with this analogy quotes
like agitating a car key in the river
going miles downstream extracting a few
drops of water and then starting one's
car with the water and quotes benveniste
stick to the science I'll handle the
explanatory metaphors
that one sucked like you managed to even
make me more confused with that one
anyway his conclusion was that water
remembers what it's contained and what
has passed through it long after those
materials are no longer president water
itself hence the short version water has
memory and Jacques benveniste wasn't the
only one to conclude this either in the
mid-1990s a man named Masaru Emoto
claimed that he could change the way
that water crystallized based on the
types of emotional energies that the
water had been exposed to in his tests
he exposed samples of water to positive
words and pictures words like love and
appreciation and pictures like elephants
and shrines as well as negative
stressful stimuli like heavy metal music
and words like you fool you suck when it
comes to water samples you're a big old
drip I've seen toilet water that's
better than you you should be ashamed of
yourself
you're the worst water ever it sounds
stupid but basically this amounted to a
man telling a glass of water to go die
and calling it science he would then
freeze the water and take pictures using
a high-powered microscopic lens he found
that water that received positive
feedback froze in elaborate geometric
designs whereas water from polluted
sources or that had been exposed to
other negative stimuli froze in ways
that were distorted he reported these
findings in a best-selling book called
messages from water and toured all over
the world to discuss and present them so
apparently water not only has memory but
it also has feelings not so fast you see
Jacque benveniste findings were a bit
troubling to the staff at nature
magazine on one hand the idea that water
could have memory was a monumental
groundbreaking finding on the other hand
it was only one experiment and
completely flew in the face of a number
of established scientific principles of
physics and chemistry so nature took the
middle ground when they published the
study they chose to include an editor's
note before the paper telling readers to
suspend their judgment until the results
could be replicated and verified and not
only that the editor went one step
further he put together a crack team of
scientists and skeptics to run tests and
one of those people was a man by the
name of James Randi now if you never
heard of this guy he is literally one of
the coolest guys ever James Randi was a
magician who turned into a professional
skeptic he developed the 1 million
dollar paranormal challenge
basically he offered to give a million
bucks to anybody who could prove the
existence of supernatural phenomena in
short he used that million dollar bribe
to lure fakers onto television and then
totally dunk on them in public the clips
on YouTube of James Randi completely
owning all these fake psychic shysters
are peak cringe at any rate when the
team's applied some controls to the
benveniste
study the results couldn't be replicated
and so nature published a notice that
disputed his initial results one month
after publishing it since then various
teams have tried over and over and over
again to replicate the water memory
findings but to no avail
as all of us in the age of social media
know once you put a juicy headline out
there for people to read like water has
memory that's the thing that's gonna
stick not the redaction that happens one
month later meanwhile Masaru of Moto's
findings have never been published by a
scientific publication mostly because
the whole thing wasn't really done in
any sort of scientific way the guy took
some water from a lake he took some
water from a polluted body and like wow
the polluted stuff froze in a really
unnatural wait well no duh something
tells me those results weren't tied to
the Slipknot you had playing on repeat
for the water and it's not just me
saying that in analyzing messages from
water dr. Harriet Hall concluded quote
emoto's popularity is a sad commentary
on the scientific illiteracy of our
society his work is a morass of factual
errors misconceptions misinterpretations
metaphors and meaningless assertions he
writes in the language of magical
thinking and superstition not of science
and quote cheese don't hold back there
Harriette and in 2005 another study that
directly addressed the structure of
memory in water determined that water
molecules can change their structure and
build onto each other but that those
structures are extremely short-lived to
quote from that paper liquid water
essentially loses the memory of
persistent correlations in its structure
within 50 femtoseconds a femtosecond is
1 million of a billion of a second to
scale a femtosecond is two a second as a
second is 230 1.7 million years so does
water have memory technically yes but
it's memory is vastly worse than Dorries
overall it's pretty safe to conclude
that Olaf's big claim throughout frozen
2 is indeed a science fiction now this
might seem unnecessarily nitpicky to
some of you ok fine so Disney stretched
the truth about science facts big deal
why are you complaining about fact
versus fiction in a movie with a magical
on melting snowman and yeah I get that
criticism and the idea of water having
memory and there being spiritual
connections with nature is pretty
on-brand for Disney heck mallanna is
pretty much all about humans having a
connection to the water but there's a
difference which is that Moana and the
original frozen don't claim to be
invoking fact in fact he goes one step
further and says it's disputed by many
but it's true he's actively telling the
audience to disregard the skeptics and
more importantly the real science that
we just covered scientific
misinformation is really easily spread
just ask your aunt about using a chopped
up onion in your sock to remove toxins
from your body yeah that's a real thing
that's circulated widely across Facebook
and no amount of logic or rebuttal is
gonna change your mind when next
Christmas she smells like the back of a
burger stand my main fear here in this
is that kids look at Disney movies with
the same level of blind faith so when a
movie tells them hey here are facts and
it's being communicated to them through
a character that they know and that they
love and trust in a movie that they
might watch dozens upon dozens of times
it's likely that they'll retain those
beliefs for years they won't question
where they got those beliefs from in the
first place
the good news is that I don't think
anyone believing that water has memory
is really gonna do them harm but it's
the principle of the whole thing if
Disney truly wants to invoke science and
it's stories then they need to be super
careful about what they say is fact just
as importantly we all need to promote
replication and independent verification
of the science that we hear about to
make sure it's credible and not just
there to grab some headlines so the next
time that you're watching frozen - with
the family remember to have a detailed
discussion with any kids who are present
about the scientific method and
replication standards
I'm sure they'll thank you for it or you
know more likely they'll probably just
tell you to let it go but hey that's
just a theory film theory and cuts
you